good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-668 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
revised as if no special containment
procedures aside from standard security
are required as CP 668 is to be
transferred to a locked safe deposit box
at site 19 s high-value item storage
facility standard defenses against
intrusion explosive chemical biological
and mimetic are to be in place at all
times according to standard operating
procedure scp-668 may only be removed
from its safe deposit box by personnel
with security clearance two or higher
individuals wishing to make use of
scp-668 outside site 19 must first
submit a form 668 requested course of
action form 205 11 and be fitted with an
explosive Killswitch collar on a 24-hour
timer before taking scp-668 into the
field an auditing officer with security
clearance 4 or higher must confirm that
a CP 668 has been returned to its safe
deposit box before the collar is
deactivated
description scp-668 is a 33 centimeter
or 13 inch chef's knife with a rosewood
handle and full tang construction
crafted at some point from the late
1930s to the early 1940s when first
acquired by field operatives scp-668 was
in badly rusted condition with heavy
pitting from blood stains and other
bodily fluids trapped in the micro
crevices within the blade following
thorough analysis these irregularities
were removed for aesthetic purposes this
had negligible if any effect on scp-668
special properties the first recorded
appearance of scp-668 was in the 1960s
during an infamous murder case a New
York woman living alone was allegedly
assaulted and murdered by an unknown
assailant despite the fact that 38
witnesses reported hearing the attack
none of them attempted to aid the young
woman for over six hours until her
eventual death whether the item received
its properties due to this event or
whether it had them beforehand is a
matter of debate see doctor paper read
the bystander effect vs. doctor theory
regarding psychic imprint ation what is
clear however are its current properties
when carried by humanoid or humanoid
entity with violent intent toward
another human or humanoid entity scp-668
broadcasts a psychic signal that renders
all sentient beings with a psionic
resistance index of 97 or lower
incapable of assisting the victim
affected entities report a sudden sense
of apathy while under scp-668 influence
sensory input is not affected and
affected entities report feeling
revulsion and horror but are simply
incapable of acting even indirectly to
assist the victim meanwhile it renders
the victim incapable of defending
themselves against their attacker tests
using Class D personnel have shown no
upper limit in the number of entities
affected by the psychic resonance in one
test 12th Class D personnel do four
first of the month termination were
placed in a room alongside a researcher
who was told to randomly select one test
subject for death the researcher killed
all test subjects one by one despite
their professed horror prior incidents
have indicated the possibility of
hundreds if not thousands of deaths due
to scp-668 unique properties see
incident reports 668 a re from mall
massacre and subsequent information
blackout operations incidents 668 a
incident retrieval of scp-668 13-inch
chef's knife personnel involved date
location description on city police
department precinct responded to reports
of a man attacking and killing buying
Stander's with a large chef's knife at a
local mall upon responding officers
discovered 15 casualties most of whom
had been ritually flensed in a manner
described by witnesses as horrific
officers discover the subject and escape
serial killer name henceforth referred
to as suspect in the child's daycare
area in the process of filling and
consuming a nine-year-old boy officers
ordered subject to cease and desist
suspect did not comply officers then
attempt to fire upon suspect but
discovered that they were unable to pull
the trigger officers then attempted to
flee but found themselves unable to do
so after suspect declared his intention
to murder every last one of you mother
[ __ ] pigs suspect proceeded to ending
with Cynthia Wallace a foundation
operative embedded as an observer with
the police department despite being
under severe psyche assault officer
Wallace a pseudonym managed to activate
her emergency transponder located in her
belt while complying with subjects
orders to alerting the foundation of the
situation
mobile task force pi-1 city slickers
arrived on the scene minutes later
disguised as an FBI anti-terrorist task
force pi-1 breached the perimeter
corresponding with the moment that
officer Wallace's vital signs telemetry
ceased transmitting Task Force members
discovered suspect standing outside
department store on the third floor of
the mall the police officers bodies were
found suspended from the third floor
railing skin fliends and arranged in the
form of wings and trails removed and
trailing to the floor
officer Wallace's body was found SCP
operatives then attempted to terminate
the subject only to discover that they
too were unable to fire their weapons
team leader transmitted 8th class one
type 73 mimetic attack alert to command
and ordered the team to withdraw this
order failed when suspect stated his
intention to find out what all your
insides look like rendering them
helpless to escape involved Task Force
members were subsequently remote
terminated using surgically installed
cranial detonators according to standard
field protocol following psychic
compromise in a field agent command
elements then authorized escalation of
force to tear to severe collateral
damage aerial bombardment was attempted
but failed when the pilots were unable
to release their payload over the target
it was thus determined that the psychic
field that prevents hostile intent
towards subject may have an infinite
range escalation of force to tier 3 was
considered but delayed while dr. gears
suggested an alternate strategy with a
higher chance to retrieve the item
[Music]
hypothesizing that hostile intent was
required for the psychic controls to
trigger doctor gears suggested using
Class D personnel under mind control by
a CP o61
previously prepared sleepwalker agents
fitted with surgically implanted
earpieces transmitting a CP o61
were given the following commands do 61
o 56 was ordered to give the following
commands to the rest of the personnel
through a radio control do 61 o 56 was
not given any indication as to the
reason for set commands to prevent the
psychic defenses from triggering agents
were able to order do 61 o 56 to give
the following orders suggesting that the
psychic defense may only be able to
function through a certain number of
iterations more research is required on
this issue the O 61 o 56 through oh
seven t12 personnel were ordered to
carry explosive charges to 12
predetermined points opening gas mains
along the way explosives were detonated
in sequence upon being given the final
order by do 61 o 56 do 61 o 99 who fit
the profile of the subjects preferred
type of victim was ordered to move to a
predetermined location at the center of
the mall to lure the suspect to the best
location for both ensuring a kill and
allowing for easy retrieval of the
remains
finally six d-class personnel not under
control by SCP O 61 were ordered to
capture the subject these Class D
personnel were not expected to complete
their mission and served as a delaying
action while the mind-controlled
operatives carried out their mission
the operation was a success by using
multiple personnel none of whom were
aware of the significance of their
actions
none of the personnel knew that their
actions were related to terminating the
suspect and were thus able to act freely
suspects remains were retrieved from the
rubble by a bomb defusing robot and
placed in a box lined with SCP 148
before being retrieved by foundation
personnel following confirmation of
capture command ordered tier 3 nuclear
detonation elements to stand down from
ready 5 status and declared the incident
contained a cover story blaming the
attack on terrorists was formulated and
disseminated to the public control
testing has determined that the subjects
weapon 13-inch chef's knife was the
active agent in the incident emitting a
psionic command that suspects remains
are to be sent to City Police Department
along with a replica knife the original
weapon is to be designated a Keter level
SCP SCP 668 and sent to site 19 or
further testing how the suspect acquired
a CP 668 is unknown at this time it is
further noted that the obsessive nature
of the subjects method of killing may
have contributed to the success of this
operation subject carried out its
killings in a ritualistic manner
maximizing the amount of horror pain and
suffering inflicted on its victims
for this reason foundation personnel
were able to keep him contained within
an enclosed area the mall and formulate
a plan of action should the subject have
made the decision to leave them all and
continue its killing spree elsewhere
immediate tier 3 responds by a double
blind operator would have been the only
possible method of containing the
incident
recovery of scp-668 in such scenarios is
problematic due to the items psychic
properties agents attempting to
apprehend the subject during containment
failure incidents are often themselves
affected by a CP 668 so-called apathy
field resulting in casualties among
foundation personnel following incident
668 a standard retrieval protocol
includes the use of a long-range sniper
rifle double-blind conditions and three
different agents working in tandem
through carefully coordinated actions to
prevent any of them realizing that they
are actively opposing the subject
because of the obvious apocalyptic
possibilities it is the recommendation
of this panel that scp-668 be designated
a Keter level threat and placed in high
level containment addendum 668 a
following further testing it has been
determined that test subjects wielding
scp-668 can be terminated through
passive response so long as the
terminating agent is introduced before
the subject takes possession of scp-668
the running man protocol see appendix
668 be approved terminating agents is
hereby approved for use with scp-668 and
the item in question is hereby
reclassified as a euclid type object
addendum 668 b use of omega 7 personnel
for retrieval of scp-668 during future
containment failure incidents is to be
hereby forbidden due to the danger of
SCP 76 - coming into contact with the
item addendum 668 b is revoked as due to
SCP 76 - s expressed distaste at using
an item that in its own words takes all
the fun out
possibility of using a CP 76 to is a
solo agent for any future containment
failure incidents under review with the
ending of the Omega 7 project no further
attempts to weaponize SCP 76 - or
scp-668 are to be attempted
addendum 668 C do not under any
circumstances allow a CP 668 to come
into contact with scp-682 note that
although average human beings have a
psionic resistance index of 24 scp-682
has been tested with a psionic
resistance index of placing an above
scp-668 threshold of effect the
possibilities of a creature inimical to
all life gaining possession of something
like this should be obvious with the
ending of the Omega 7 project no further
attempts to weaponize scp-682 or scp-668
are to be attempted addendum 668 d
request to reclassify scp-668 under its
original designation as a Keter class
object under review addendum 668 e
request to reclassify a CP 668 under its
original designation as a Kenner class
object denied scp-668 will remain at
euclid classification
you know sometimes I really don't
understand people this thing is not
quatre
you guys ever heard of the locked box
test anyway I don't want to get into
this right now frankly I just want to
have some lunch so I'm gonna leave it
here thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert geum's Saba
chris ball pablo ice 917 kareem al a
smaii justin day Thomas Morin Traver w
peg white crew and jayvo check my
archive curator neck tie verbal quartz
five six three and the wanderer thank
you all so much for your support I
really appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]